a trailblazer and role model for women
and girls in science gets honored today
here in nevada alex
she is incredible this is dr catherine
sullivan
she's a triple world record holder in
space
and sea exploration tonight governor
steve sisilak will present her
with this year's desert research
institute nevada medal of science award
dr sullivan was the first woman to walk
in space for nasa
and just last year she became the first
woman to reach the challenger into the
mariana trench
and that is the deepest part of the
ocean
leaving the planet to go to outer space
is an explosive event
it's very short it's very intense it
only takes eight and a half minutes to
get into orbit
leaving the surface of the earth to go
to the bottom of the deep sea
is a much more peaceful calm smooth
uh it's you know like a serene elevator
ride basically
she talks about it like a trip to the
store it's so casual to her
she also helped launch and maintain the
hubble space telescope
also served as administrator for noaa
among so many other accomplishments
i asked her what advice she had for
girls and women who want to follow in
her footsteps
if you're really interested in science
or think you want to be an astronaut or
a firefighter
you'll bump into people who think it's
odd that you that that interests you and
that's you're not what girls
should do uh and when when you meet that
person
what you want to remember is that nobody
gets to edit what you're interested in
your interests are your interests and
you are completely
allowed and entitled to explore and
develop those interests
into whatever they may become in your
life that's a picture of her with sally
ride
that says they were waiting to board the
space shuttle challenger back on
uh it was october of 1984 so
she's just had an incredible career
she's such a role model for so many
that ceremony by the way it's tonight at
five it will all be virtual
just have to register first at
nevadametal m-e-t-a-l-dot-com but it was
such a pleasure to talk to her we all
got to talk to her as a big panel of
people
and uh we were supposed to have it just
a couple of minutes and we
we just kept having questions because
she's so interesting she's doing so much
stuff
you've got to ask a lot of questions a
lot of things to dive into that good
stuff literally dive into